we begin with a very serious story where
investigators in California say DNA
evidence led them to one of the
country's most notorious serial killers
former police officer Joseph James
D'Angelo was arrested yesterday and he
is believed to be the so-called Golden
State Killer that elusive predator is
accused of about 50 rapes and 12 murders
crimes that terrorized California in the
1970s and 80s John Blackstone is outside
the Angelo's home in Citrus Heights near
Sacramento where the suspect was taken
into custody
John good morning this is quite a story
it is a good morning and as you can see
investigators are still pouring through
this home here looking for evidence two
years ago a law enforcement task force
jump-started new efforts to catch the
Golden State killer and the big break
came only a few days ago in the
formative advanced new DNA technology
all of a sudden in six a period of time
we've solved the case of the century
Sacramento District Attorney anne-marie
Schubert made the stunning announcement
on Wednesday we found the needle in the
haystack and it was right here in
Sacramento police say Joseph James
D'Angelo is the Golden State killer who
terrorized Californians during a
harrowing crime spree that began over 40
years ago we started some surveillance
we were able to get some discarded DNA
and we were able to confirm what we
thought we already knew that we had our
man D'Angelo was an ex-police officer
who became a suspect in the last week
identified using what authorities would
only describe as a sophisticated new
kind of DNA technology the 72 year old
D'Angelo has been charged with eight
murders in Sacramento Orange and Ventura
counties but is suspected in several
other killings and dozens of rapes many
of the crimes were committed just miles
from his home in Citrus Heights where he
was arrested on Tuesday in the past year
a special episode of 48 hours helped
keep the case in the public eye as well
as the best-selling book written by
Michelle McNamara the late wife of
comedian Patton Oswalt who praised his
wife last night
her book and her and the article that
led to the book really amped up all the
interest in the case and really put a
lot of focus on this the Golden State
Killer hunted and haunted his victims
from 1974 to 1986 raping women while
their husbands or boyfriends were tied
up nearby he even took souvenirs of his
crimes and made frightening phone calls
to survivors
[Applause]
Bruce Harrington's brother and
sister-in-law were two of the alleged
victims for the 51 ladies who were
brutally raped in this crime scene sleep
better tonight he isn't coming through
the window Lindo dell is one of those
women raped by the Golden State killer
in 1977 deputy Carol Daley took her to
the hospital we just didn't give up
no DeAngelo worked for 27 years in a
local supermarket warehouse he he just
retired he was an officer in two
California Police Department's back in
the 1970s investigators are trying to
determine if he committed any of his
crimes while he was on duty as a police
officer or whether his knowledge of
police work helped him evade capture for
all these years he will be arraigned on
Friday
John John thanks what an amazing story